foreign
I think the most difficult stage of
parenting is when you can't anymore
because they're grown yeah
they get to make their own decisions
and uh and it's also the most difficult
thing of any adult to adult relationship
because you don't get to tell the
someone you love what to do while you
watch them do something stupid or
harmful or disastrous or whatever and so
if you've got a friend that's drinking
too much you've got a friend that's
doing something outside their marriage
or shouldn't be doing you got a friend
or a family member but you can't tell
other people what you can tell other
people what to do but they don't have to
do it yeah and uh even though you know
that what they're doing is
self-destructive and even though it's
not for selfish intent that you're
asking them to do that we're not trying
to that kid's dad at 32 years old with
five kids under seven is not trying to
do something harmful to him by trying to
get him get a job
um take care of his family uh but but
something broke something slipped in the
in that young man somewhere along the
line and um you you
a couple things that always come up in
the world of finance and even in the
world of careers as well that are over
are under the heading of what Dr deloney
talks about and teaches all the time
what John talks about is
um I can't
be responsible for
nor do I have the literal ability to
make an adult do something else I can
make them wish they did sometimes
but I can't make them do it they have to
decide to do it
and so Henry Cloud always says don't
don't use words like you need to because
they obviously don't need to you should
they obviously don't think that instead
you could just say this is these you
know here's some ideas here persuasion
is your only option uh ordering people
around and
and being completely torn up inside
which I have been you have been she was
watching someone yes that you love
self-destruct yeah
um is a natural thing to be but but
you're doubly torn up inside when you
feel like you have the obligation to fix
it yeah well it's the illusion of
control exactly and we we so desire to
help out a friend or family member and
you have to be able to just live with
the pain you do you just have to be able
to hurt you hurt yourself uh you hurt
for them you watch them hurt yeah and
it's terrible but the reality is is that
I think you're right Dave persuasion but
you got to be careful with persuasion
you know it it can only go so far and
then they begin to drown you out you may
take one or two good cracks at it well
persuasion is fine in prayer I mean it's
um it's God to send people into their
path that they will listen to but all of
that comes down to them making a
decision why would they make a decision
to do something differently well it can
be facts it could be emotion it can be
influence it could be whatever but it's
it is never coercion that's correct yeah
they you like you said a million times
you you they'll make the decision at
some point or they want to deal with the
sick and tired they're sick and tired
one of the things you learn when you're
running a business and you're leading a
team you can't make people do stuff
there you cannot now there are companies
are so stupid they try to make people do
stuff but those are toxic environments
all you can do is create an environment
to where there are natural consequences
if you don't do it like you don't get to
work here anymore
but this is what we expect and when you
don't do this you don't get to work here
anymore and this is what we expect and
if you do do this then you know you're
not only going to get to work here
you're going to make more money you're
made in your life you're going to have a
great life you're going to be part of a
winning team you know you get to
participate in um incredible uh Crusade
all of those things but you can always
choose to engage in behaviors that cause
you to opt out let me ask you a
generational question do you feel like
over the last
30 50 years that the focus on safety
just in general as a culture and I'm not
being silly when I say this but bike
helmets and elbow pads you know car
seats things that we know are safe but
we didn't grow up with I just wonder if
parents have gotten to the point where
we're afraid to let our kids experience
pain maybe the one thing that can turn
their life around is that a shift or is
nothing shifted in your as you look back
oh it's probably accelerated some I mean
the helicopter parents are at a whole
new level now we have Blackhawk
helicopter isn't that the truth these
were like traffic cops hovercraft we
have all different types but the uh uh
but it's a different thing they're
attack copters now but the uh uh
loudspeakers
but anyway that you know yeah it's
probably amped up but it does it always
comes from
all enabling
comes from a good heart what parent
functional parents I'm not talking about
dysfunctional but functional parents
always want their kids life to be better
than theirs was
and there's a point of diminishing
returns on that oh and or also there's
not only appointed admission returns
worse than that we can if we're not
careful when we're enabling what that
leads to we can uh
misdefine put the wrong definition of
what a better life is a life devoid of
struggle is not a better life oh
let me try that again a life devoid of
struggle is not a better life
and so we tried to let our kids
experience pain while they were at home
under the covering of our wings yes so
that we could control the level of pain
because when you get out out outside the
home I can't help you anymore the level
of pain can become unbearable that's
true it can put you in an institution I
mean it could be completely overwhelming
because you can do stupid and the the
the you know it's Decades of health
problems Decades of brain damage that
follows that Decades of broken and torn
relationships the rest of your life that
are marred by that by your I can't keep
you from making those decisions once
you're outside my so we try to let our
kids you know fall over and go okay you
got to deal with that I'm not going to
go over and fix that conflict here's how
you deal with conflict go work on that
and they would do it wrong sometimes oh
sure and but all within so a life devoid
of struggle is not necessarily a better
life and when you as a parent and that's
a little bit of the bike helmet thing
you know the the thing is we want there
to be a hundred percent Zero fatalities
100 zero whatever but that means that no
kids ever jumped over anything on their
bicycle yeah and that would be a shame
yeah
it would be a shame it's also a shame
when one of them gets hurt I was hurt I
get stitches all over my body doing that
crap and uh I'm not you know I'm not I
don't want children to be harmed I'm not
that stupid right but this idea that you
can completely remove
um
yeah all risk from life and still have a
high quality life you know I just jumped
out of an airplane the other day yes you
did I watched you I watched you float
down you watched me from the ground I
wasn't ready folks I need to hey I need
to baby step my way you should have seen
the plane he went up in well and you
can't you you can't say stuff like he
left it all on the ground no you can't
you left it all on the field uh you
can't say lines like that no you can't
you know one thing we
where we are not even trying to just
eliminate pain for our kids Dave now
we're trying to eliminate unpleasantness
yeah and so now it's all about I want my
kid to feel it because you need a safe
space when you're triggered and all this
ridiculous if it's if it's all about
making our kids feel good we'll miss the
part of going out to college tenured
professors and they're not reasonable
human beings no and so by and large yeah
and so uh you know that it's but now
it's all about Junior getting out
without a single ever having his little
feelings hurt or his ideas if I actually
disagree with you it completely shuts
some of you down yeah you can't deal
with it because you've had zero conflict
ever in your life to process right you
got to do it you know so your critical
thinking skills are mush I wish we had
some data on how quickly uh my
generation learned to ride a bike versus
the kids of today because here's the
deal if you wrecked when when I was a
kid you stuck to the sheets for a week
you know now they got more pads on them
than you could throw well it makes the
point doesn't it I don't remember
sticking to the sheets no skin on your
knees oh yeah if you wrecked a bike in
mind yeah I know but kind of leaked back
in my day oh my God you sound like that
guy this is the guy who used to say get
up and spray some Bactine on it now it's
too much for popping there's a throwback